when you hear the phrase and forgive me
it I know this is kind of cliche but
like follow your dreams okay does that
have the same meaning to you now as it
did when let's say your acting teacher
drove you down to LA from Ventura or
early 20s yes it still does absolutely
okay why I think the biggest struggle is
holding on to that feeling because when
you don't know anything it's all awesome
you know I mean I have no idea how the
business works you just know what you
want to do and so you go and you do it
and you're exuberant about it and you
love it and you do it all the time it's
awesome and then you get into the
business and you start getting told no I
say no no no no and so then you start
going oh okay well this thing that I
really love and dig I should adjust it
I'm gonna move it yeah I'll do this cuz
then I can get that no I better change
this thing around and then you're not
doing it because you love it you're just
you're just trying to win you know I
mean I just need to win now once I win
everything's are and you lose sight of
the passion of it you know you're a kid
man you don't think about okay well if
we're gonna play cops and robbers Oh see
am I the captain in the office or maybe
I'm a lieutenant
are we undercover you don't think about
any of it there's cop a rapper you know
I mean like I'm the cop here the Robert
it's fun and I think we lose that
because of the complexities of the way
the industry works and it's hard to hold
on to but yeah III work my best to hold
on to that than that feeling and it's
why I love writing so much because when
you're a writer you just all by yourself
with your story
you know and if you can block out all
the white noise of people telling you
what you should write you just write
what you want to write it's great it's
great you can see it you can feel it you
get out there and you're happy to
deliver that script to people and pass
it around the representatives or
producers or actors or whoever you have
access to let's try to get this thing
happening and it's that's the best so
yeah you got it you gotta keep following
you gotta keep following the dream do
you ever have trouble blocking out time
to write no you don't know I just love
writing it's just fun for me you know
some people like to go to bars I like a
glass of wine a little jazz I like to
write I know it's a difficult thing I
think it's a lot of people I've spoken
with if it's daunting for them which is
like stare at that blank screen I
started teaching screenwriting with a
program called page 1/2 done to help
people because I knew there are a lot of
people that were like going to these
courses and they buying these books then
it seems to me like I could be wrong but
it seems to me like the books almost
make people hesitant to write at all and
my my course the goal is to actually by
the time it's over to have a finished
screenplay I get you writing right away
just right you just it doesn't have to
be perfect like you don't have to you
don't have to have a written pulp
fiction
you know what I mean you're not gonna
write pulp fiction you know you're gonna
look at what you've written and you're
not gonna like it that's the only means
that you've got excellent excellent
taste like you you you love really great
stuff so you know you just have to start
anything and you'll get better at it and
it's it's always hard to start so I
always tell people you remember when you
were baby alright so you're a baby and
you didn't know how to walk right so you
crawled right and then you finally got
up on your feet and then you fell so
what you do
probably cried yeah you try it again
well yeah obviously now you're a
professional right you can walk you can
walk in heels I bet even yeah probably
walking heel backward you can dance you
can run that's like an advanced walking
technique you know what I mean
you just kept doing it that's all it is
you just keep doing it you just keep
doing it and you're gonna get better
it's the law of averages you're gonna
get better if you keep doing something
you know
you